My opponent tonight
is outgoing president
of Planned Parenthood,
Cecile Richards.
-Her new memoir...
-(cheers and applause)
Her brand-new memoir is called
Making Trouble:
Standing Up, Speaking Out,
and Finding the Courage
to Lead.
Guess what?
You don't need courage to lead.
Just ask Paul Ryan.
Cecile Richards, everybody.
-Hey. Good to see you, Jordan.
-Cecile, welcome.
-Good to see you. Yeah.
-Good to see you.
So, Cecile,
today is officially
your last day as president
of Planned Parenthood
after 12 years.
12 years, that's right.
Did you find Jesus?
If so, welcome to the flock.
Uh, I've been so honored to do
this job for 12 years.
Planned Parenthood
is actually one
of the most popular
organizations in the country,
even according to Fox News.
Uh, uh, in fact, um...
(cheers and applause)
And, uh, one in five women
in this country
have been to us for health care.
And I'm so proud
of the work we've done,
and I'm ready to make room
for somebody else to lead
the organization now.
Now, you claim
that Planned Parenthood
-is not in the federal budget.
-That's exactly correct.
But then why am I so mad
about the federal budget funding
Planned Parenthood
and abortions?
Yeah, so, I don't know why
you're mad, but, uh...
I need an answer.
I'm-I'm furious.
So Planned Parenthood operates
like all other health care
providers in the country.
We get reimbursed
for preventive services
like birth control, which
is very popular in America.
We do pap smears,
we do breast exams,
and all of that is reimbursed
just like hospitals.
Federal funding does not pay
for abortion,
except in very limited
circumstances.
So we operate
like everyone else.
Now I heard it is paid for
by the federal--
And my-my uncle sells-- sends
out this, uh, this tweet,
and he also has an e-mail
-with a bunch of information
and pictures on it. -Right.
-And that's been going around
for years. -Right.
Well, in fact, he's wrong.
And so is a lot of congress,
and that's why, actually,
there's been such an outpouring
of support around the country,
especially among women,
when this president
and this congress tried to,
you know, defund, as they said,
or prevent women from coming
to Planned Parenthood.
We were able to beat back
the efforts
to both defund
Planned Parenthood
and repeal Obamacare.
And Planned Parenthood's doors
are still open
all across the United States
of America.
Now, you had a meeting
with, uh, "Javanka,"
Jared and Ivanka, in 2017.
-That's correct. -In this book,
you talk a little bit about it,
that they made you
a very good offer--
you and Planned Parenthood--
What happened?
Well, so Ivanka Trump
had said she wanted to meet
to talk about
Planned Parenthood,
because her father had said he
was going to defund us again.
And I thought, well,
if there's any chance
to make my case, uh, I,
you know, wanted to do that.
I did make my husband
come with me,
so that I have a witness.
But actually, really they,
they didn't want to talk too
much about Planned Parenthood.
Pretty much Jared Kushner said
if we would quit
providing access
to safe and legal abortion,
which we will not,
then he would actually
get more federal funding
for Planned Parenthood.
And I just said,
"Look, we're not gonna trade off
women's rights
in this country for money."
That's just not who we are.
(cheers and applause)
That sounds like a deal.
You got to give a little
to take a little.
Well, we're not making deals
about women's health
and women's rights.
And actually,
Ivanka did say, she said,
"Well, you have to understand
my father's pro-life."
I said, "Well, he can have
his own opinion,
but he can't take away
the rights of millions
of American women that make
their own decisions
about their pregnancy.
-And, uh, and also...
-(cheers and applause)
I mean, I s-- you know, I...
(stammers)
How can he say he's pro-life
when he's trying
to deport dreamers,
take away health care
from millions of people
in this country
,and maternity benefits,
all of the things that this
administration is trying to do?
So I-I just feel
like he really needs
to rethink what his values are.
Well, he's very pro-his life.
Yeah. (laughs)
That may be it.
You've said that if members of
congress could get pregnant,
a lot of issues would be solved.
-Don't you think?
-Well, but I...
I have an issue with that.
How are old white men
over the age of 50
-going to get pregnant?
-Exactly. Exactly.
It doesn't make any sense,
like...
Yes, no, I think
that's exactly right.
In fact, I remember
when one of the senators said
that he thought
we shouldn't even be covering
maternity benefits for women
because he was never
going to need them.
So, I guess, apparently,
he was past
his childbearing years.
And, uh... But thank--
this is why we need more women
in office.
Debbie Stabenow,
the senator from Michigan,
said, "Well,
I bet your mother did,"
and actually, we were able
to get maternity benefits
for millions of women.
But this administration
is trying to take them away.
Are you just
inciting violence here?
Make Trouble.
What are you getting at?
-I think it's important. I-I...
-Just look at this pi...
-This feels like just an antifa
handbook. -It's getting your...
-All of this. -It's getting
you agitated right there.
-It's just... It's so angry.
-(laughs)
It's, uh... You know,
right after the election,
every day it seemed like
someone stopped me on the street
and said, "What can I do?
I need to do something more."
And I decided instead of talking
to every single person
on the subway--
-as some people try to do...
-Don't do that.
-Trust me, yeah.
-Yeah, I'm not gonna do that--
that I would put it
in a book instead.
And I hope
it's kind of a call to action
and a little bit of a memoir.
And what I have seen
around the country
is that women
are doing everything.
They're, you know,
they're marching,
they're going
to town hall meetings,
they're calling
their members of Congress.
But what we've got
to really make sure
is that this November
they're going to vote,
'cause that's how we're gonna
change the direction of America.
(cheering and applause)
All those women out there,
I hear voting in December
is much cooler.
Tell me something
I already know.
Well, I think it's maybe just
something you need to know
is that Planned Parenthood
actually now has
twice the membership
of the National Rifle
Association.
-(cheering and applause)
-And so, um, I just...
Birth control and Planned
Parenthood are really popular,
so maybe you should switch
your allegiances.
-That's my idea.
-Those numbers can't be right.
-It's absolutely right.
-They can't be right.
-It's absolutely true. -I hope
those numbers aren't right.
They're right. They're correct.
Her new memoir is called
Making Trouble.
Cecile Richards.
The fight continues.